mic prayer has it been that long my god
this is my eighth season coming up with
Fox okay Mike
time flies by it flies by so it's
blended when you're my age are you
making Blandino carrier bags or sing
sing is college faculty carry carries my
bags he's going to buy my newspaper form
he's going to give me my coffee in the
morning before we go on air you know
he's going to do is due diligence when
it comes to working with me mm-hmm
good for you Mike that's the way you
roll fox rules analysts from back in the
day at the NFL officiating office Mike
Pereira here on the show how is this
going to work
the NFL's plan to make 21 to 24 current
part-time officials full-time well I'll
tell you it's a work in progress because
I don't think the leak even knows how
it's going to work and neither does the
Union look I think they I think they've
named it wrongly I have to clear this
locale to look and see what's underneath
and and to me it's not full-time I mean
that they're saying it's full-time but
really all that is happening here is
that the league is going to get access
to 21 to 24 of the officials during what
is called the dark period and that's in
their collective bargaining agreement
that basically says that the league
cannot contact the officials from the
end of the regular season until May 15
except for playoff games or physicals or
special clinics that they need to you
know help somebody that's struggling and
what this is really only going to do is
get these 24 that aren't going to be in
that dark period and they can use them
for mentoring other officials and they
can also use them if they wanted to go
to an OTA or a mini camp but they're
going to have to pay them each time they
do leave their house to perform a
function that the leek asked them to do
and there's no clarity in that yet and
so I think the other thing to recognize
here is they still can have another job
that the NFL is not telling them that
they can't work another job but they are
telling them that they have first rights
to access so if you've got a jeans
territor who if he chose to do it I mean
if they if you wanted to continue to
work basketball he could if the league
wanted him for a project that would
conflict with the n-c-double-a
basketball game then the NFL would win
out but it remains to be seen how much
these guys will be used what their
duties are going to be and if the league
really wants to put out the money you
know to get them to go to mini camps and
training camps and all that kind of
stuff okay so you just laid a lot out
there so first things you know me know I
know that so the because when you here
full-time refereeing you're thinking
these guys are just that's it they 24/7
365 they're in the rulebook they're in a
study room they're in a film room
they're constantly working on the
National Football League and you're
saying that is not going to be the case
even though we don't hate your see it's
not like they do not they stick them in
a hermetically sealed room and say learn
the rulebook and don't come on the case
not the case now they do a lot of the
stuff like you're talking about on their
own all the time you know if you were
going to say that they were going to be
full-time and you'd say okay then we're
going to pay him like if a major league
baseball umpire or NBA basketball
officials but that's not the case you're
taking they're they're going to continue
to be members of the Union they won't be
quote-unquote full-time employees of the
league with benefits that come from the
league all they're going to do is
basically be paid a stipend to be
available during that dark period which
you know is a $40,000 stipend basically
for each of the 24 and then they'll get
paid additional meeting fees every time
they go out but think about it I mean
you can still have another job other
than the times that you're asked to go
to an OTA or minicamp you're probably
doing the same thing that you are doing
anyways which is helping the mentor
other officials that were struggling so
I'm not saying it's a bad move I think
it's a step in the direction that you
know that needs to be taken but you know
to me it's like the league is
okay we got it we've got a sore here we
got it we got a cold sore and they're
just putting a bandaid on the cold sore
instead of really trying to rectify the
whole problem and I give them I give
them the fact that they are taking a
step but don't call it full time because
that's really not what it is
so then my career Fox for joins me what
would full time looked like then for you
if you wait one SATs ruffles on whole
time to me is and it's a program that I
always thought they should have done
that's to take the 17 referees those
that have the most influence in the
league and make them full time which
means during the season they go to an
officiating Institute they break down
everything together all 17 together all
the time and they're involved with
everything and and to me that was the
next step that needed to be taken you
know whole claim so you make proper
announcements those types of things
because the referees really really do
carry the influence of the entire crew
by the way they project themselves to me
that was the next snip make sure that
they have constant consistent messaging
that goes out to their 17 crews this
doesn't do that I mean this this works
basically in the offseason to try to
make people other officials better but
um again I just don't see it as the know
shouldn't be in Kolkata
so how much money were you talking about
because you know you always got to
follow the money here I mean you talk
about well if you follow the money trail
I mean that you know basically if they
hire up to 24 people each will get
$40,000 to be available as a staff know
but the way that you're talking about it
don't mine oh and the way I'm talking
about it well if you do that then I
think what you have to do I thought it
was pretty simple what you have to do is
you take a look at a 20 year baseball
umpire in a 20 year NBA basketball
official and then that's what you've got
to pay you got to pay a 20 year guy in
the NFL the same amount to be full-time
because essentially you'd be true
full-time during
season but that's a pretty good sum of
money but I you know I think just by the
sense of where they are in this I don't
think they have any interest in going
that direction what they're going to pay
full time money to have full-time
officials that don't do anything else I
mean let's face it jeans territory's not
going to give up his lucrative
n-c-double-a basketball career as a
referee if he had to under this under
this agreement so you're not going to
see him be one of the 24 because he
couldn't afford NC NC double-a
basketball in December basically so
you're free if you have the flexibility
of a job to do whatever you want during
the season in the offseason but the NFL
has first dibs on you if they want to
give you a project we will see what that
project and how many of those they give
to the 21 to 24 so Brockman helped me
out with this did Mike Pereira say that
gene starett or can't get better at NFL
officiating because he's too busy
screwing up the Big Ten made a mess up
today just in the Big East the ACC let's
name a mom why this great was a big it
sounded like it so it so what I just
turned out of like it yeah so if if the
NFL followed the Pereira Institute of
higher refereeing plan how would that
make it better on a Sunday how would I
try Madison Eisley I think that you're
17 most important officials are the
referees they are what they call the
leaders of the crew yes I'm they are the
ones that teach their other six guys
they are the ones that give them the
messages that that come from the league
office and what happens is sometimes
these messages you know don't get
translated to the 17 crews all the same
and to me they are the brightest they
ought to be involved in all the decision
making process they ought to make sure
that their announcements that they have
the proper preparation for their
announcements that they all our rule
experts which most of
are close to being anyways it's almost
impossible to be perfect with with this
rulebook but you know to me if they were
the leaders of the crew they were
together the 17 referees were all
together looking at the same place all
week with the same messages messages I
do think it would make officiating more
consistent and if you ask any coach on
in the league
any general manager any owner the one
issue that they always talk about is
consistency and you know judgment is one
thing but consistent application of the
rule and the point of emphasis is
something everybody wants and I think
you would improve that so a couple last
questions for you Mike Pereira Fox
Sports rules analyst former head of NFL
officiating if this were offered to you
the two years you were an NFL official
would you have signed up for this new
position this way what what the NFL is
currently offering it currently would
you say would have I would have flown on
my own nickel to New York to sign up for
I'd be ended up doing I'll be doing
mostly the same thing I've been doing
but get paid extra money poit I think it
was a a win for the officials and I
think it was a PR move by the league in
them and I don't think it really dresses
addresses the issue it's step but I'm
not even sure that the league when you
have a new change of leadership with you
know Blandino out in al Riverrun in I'm
not sure how they're going to implement
this and I'm not sure they know how
they're going to implement this it's
certainly going to be a work in progress
and you know to me though not a not at
all a significant step like some people
are trying to make it out to be I
applaud them for taking the first step
but it doesn't go far and and so when
it's all said and done your best you can
tell as to who's going to apply and who
will be accepted do you think people in
Phoenix Arizona seeking legal advice
will still be able to walk into the
offices of Jones Skelton and Ed Hochuli
and get the advice of mr. biceps of
Health will he be there well when he
what when they walked into the office of
Jones and Skelton and hock Tilly in
Phoenix
he would actually say I'm sorry mr.
Hockley is living on the beach in San
Diego so if you want to reach him you
better go take a plane to San Diego and
he ain't doing this at any very much
anymore so unless you want to talk to
one of our other attorneys you're out of
luck
what about that Wow about that I didn't
know so edge not really do much legal
stuff anymore so you say no no it is
enjoying the fruits of his work in India
that he put in as a lawyer he's doing
some a little bit of site work for that
firm but you know he's enjoying the
fruits of the ocean in San Diego and a
in a great relationship with a
relatively new wife and he's enjoying
kind of watching his son progress in the
NFL and within I am going to say within
three years you will see Ed Hochuli step
all now the feel don't tell me like and
in the his shoes will be Shawn oculi his
son and he will spend the rest of the
time proudly watching his kid work hmm
so he got three years left and and and
so uh last one when Ed was doing legal
work more than he has do you know uh
what did he did he wear a smedium suit
as well he showed all he did is come on
man he did this closing arguments in the
tanktop
thank you you wanted to take full
advantage and gentlemen of the jury
after further review I must say I did my
biceps work today how do you like me now
that's what that was his closing
argument Sencha okay that was in Michael
of you will chat soon you got it you
guys Mike Burke so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show lap
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show